là ça bouge nous sommes à caen au
bazarnaom pour le retour de filles 2
avec marie-laure ces deux villes
mise en scène jacques décombe à ton avis
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont penser les gens
d'une fille qui déchirent les affiches
de sa mère coupable alors qu'est ce que
tu as à dire pour sa défense
vous êtes en plein travail sur base un
homme pour une représentation qui aura
lieu ce vendredi à 20h30
oui j'ai dit ce que je pensais à ce
monsieur vis d'eux c'est une pièce en
solo qui dresse le portrait d'une
notable qui se présentent aux sélections
jeunes bien dassin ville toute
ressemblance avec certains politiques
n'est pas tout à fait fortuit les gens
parce que ça donne l'impression que tu
as envie de rsa la gendarmerie longtemps
où ils vont ça commence à bien faire
elle est dans un commissariat on lui
reproche d'avoir renversé quelqu'un dans
la rue elle n'a pas envie de s'y
attarder elle veut partir donc si elle
croise les jambes c'est qu'elle
s'installe c'est qu'elle est bien là où
est née et qu'elle veut rester c'est une
sorte de symbole et toujours aimer
l'autre petit je rangeais bien mais
jouer
d'ailleurs pour être sûr qu'il reste
bien rangé je ne sortais pas dans boîte
d'emballage
non je veux pas avec mais il était bien
rangé
même chose avec mes crayons de couleur
je laissais paraît bien les uns des
autres chacun sa place parce que sinon
dès que ça se relâche
ça se mélange canton chaussettes si on
les laisse faire
elle fournit qu à l'or noir gris jaune
tout ce petit monde se mélange et le
mélange c'est quoi vos commandes en bas
c'est le chaos encore plus de deux temps
l'objectif pour la manchoise marie laure
sénoville c'est le festival off
d'avignon où les jours à trois semaines
en juillet et il faut le savoir pour
jouer là bas il faut payer un loyer
donc on paye pour rejouer pour être vue
et avoir la chance de croiser un maximum
de programmateurs dans le but d'être
diffusé le plus largement et moi d'avoir
ma tournée mais deux années qui suivent
avec un carnet de commandes bien rempli
oui j'ai lu et disques durs appel à
souscription pour soutenir marie-laure
mai mais puisque maintenant ce bien
reprendre par les femmes
alors fallait sur osez tous acteurs
point fr c'est le site il suffit de sus
de
de devenir un souscripteur donc on a qu
on clique on donne ce qu'on veut mais il
ya les contreparties marrante qu'est ce
que c'est que ça nantes à barbie
princesse peintes en noir parmi mandela
ça fait plaisir à voir idées noires va
demander michael jackson si ça lui a
fait plaisir d'être noir je rappelle que
le spectacle a lieu ce vendredi à 20h30
ici au bazarnaom merci beaucoup jacques
et marie laure vous allez continuer à
travailler je vous laisse partir car je
sais que le travail est important à les
hydres il ajouté pourquoi demain soir un
salon au normandy un festival de tribute
red hot chili peppers téléphone a cédé 6
encore zz top
ce sont les banques et pour tarir j'ai
dit dès mardi girlfriend jaune
by next l'allemagne évidemment je sens
que ça commence à qui pointe unique
qu'est ce que jean fils elle aime bien
faire dans une soirée recadre castéra
c'est pas du tout attention il faut
quand même pas me chauffer trop trop
trop si on donne un ampli qui va jusqu'à
11 et une guitare digne de ce nom il ya
médiator du snow si je peux lâcher les
chiens belle soirée tribute demain soir
au normandy à saint lô avec les canaris
vous allez entendre sonner les cloches
ce soir le festival danses de tous les
sens accueil le chorégraphe israélien
roj
assaf à 20h30 au forum de falaise pour
un spectacle intitulé six ans plus tard
et la colline
nera de retour à caen à l'espace tandem
c'est demain à 20h30
après leur succès au big band café
d'hérouville le groupe pony pony run run
est à la luciole demain à alençon 21h
moi j'aime ça j'utilise des vieilles
voûtes hier qu elles sont vieilles mieux
sa mort parce qu'il ya plein de
concrétions et le et surtout la couleur
du ciel est la même que
au naturel gerben expose ses toiles
peintes à la mjc prairie de caen
jusqu'au 3 mai
le festival intertice ce sont des
expositions mais aussi des performances
dans ce registre à lien matthew maurice
et le collectif père obscur de caen
s'associent pour présenter golem ce soir
et demain à 20 heures à l'école des
beaux-arts de caen
et pour terminer le soutien du centre
dramatique national aux intermittents du
spectacle c'était d'hier soir pendant la
représentation de vera le rideau est
tombé et les intermittents ont défilé
avant d'entamer un débat à la fin du
spectacle les intermittents que vous
retrouverez bien évidemment non jazz
sous les pommiers